uh so listen you just basically said all
of toronto is beautiful i'm a
torontonian so you're my new best friend
oh thank you we love people who say
we're beautiful i mean it i was i was
giving a big shout out to toronto in the
city of toronto it's being one of the
most beautiful cities in the world
yeah and specifically the people um
specifically me i'm just kidding he's
never met me yeah we've we just met
yeah but you look like you're from
toronto thank you
what does that mean energy i mean in a
positive way yeah so what's the energy
like in montreal montreal is mad
a lot of french energy
a lot of i'm better than you energy
but this festival is really great yeah
yeah yeah um is it a bit of a date night
with you and your lady i started a
beautiful green dress oh yeah my wife's
here it just feels like
tonight is the last show of my king's
jester tour it's the very last show the
tour before we put out the special
it's um
we have this amazing award show tonight
or today actually because it's the day
um and jfl was just one of the first
festivals i really popped at years ago
they kind of discovered me and so it
just felt right it felt like a family
affair so i told my wife she doesn't
come to a lot of shows but i was like
you should be here for this so then this
is a bit of a full circle moment for you
than getting stand-up comedian of the
year man it's a big deal yeah and
specifically the other winners today
because i feel like they're better
comedians than me so the fact that i'm
in the same category as james and taylor
and jarad is like
yeah
it's a big deal somebody somebody at jfl
kind of like stuffed the ballot box for
me and i appreciate that i love that so
much um also i just want to ask about
your charity basketball game with our
one of our favorite canadians simulu yes
what was that like well i mean i have a
a bone to pick with cimu simu stacked
his team so there was a conflict of
interest when you're doing a celebrity
basketball game you can't have former
nba players on your team
so
this awards show aside
um
i do think simu
has a huge apology he owes all of us
massive conflict of interest and dare i
say
it was a huge sign of corruption on your
part as an organizer and a host of the
event
so simu you owe us an apology
and i don't want to vague me a culpa i
want like a real in-person apology and i
want
an in-feed instagram apology to me
not a story that'll delete 24 hours
later i want an in-feed apology
your move sema
i love that yeah
amazing you're the best so nice seeing
you yeah
you